pub
pétitions général c'est le bon dieu qui
va compter les points ouais ouais les
points du match de cet après midi mais
roj
allison et bien fort et je veux qu'on
l'entende jusqu'à la bastide et tu m'en
fais s'unissent patiente devant le sari
pour jouer donc je te dis que tu m'as
fait sonner 60 comme ça deux trois idées
là et cetera jusqu'à 60 et 62 points de
victoire pour la femme et trois petits
coups de claques comme ça trois petits
coups de la défaite pour lequel à ceux
de la fierté de la bastide 62 à 3 ça
fera juste le score du match de cet
après-midi 62 à 3 510 ch c'est pas le
plus fort pour l'appeler son affection
ericsson va et surtout n'oublie pas les
trois coups de la haine juste une misère
le coup forme de la fierté de la
bastille n'est justement que bien du
rugby tu es aux hommes qu'aux femmes
perdues 20 ème mn que le canton ne pas
tarder exxon samba victoire de l'as rome
ça te colombe
m
mme encore succombé
après
vraiment vraiment très très très joli
mais vous devriez plutôt chanter que la
rafale démarre en trombe et finissent
comme une bombe et pousse la fierté dans
la tombe au cndd colonnes au fait que
nous le remarquions 62 points 3 je vais
prendre une photo de la statue de de
commandes de cofidis et clovis oui pour
mettre en première page du bulletin
paroissial
je voulais c'est continuer c'est très
joli que la enfin
démontrons
qu'elle finisse comme
au port les bouches à la piété dans
accor
oh
j'ai classels tonique de la branche air
china
mission accomplie à la confection de
votre écoute et vous avoir fait
atteindre ashton au nouveau conclusion
la fin de mon humble avis mme roig cette
année peu ma fierté c'est en colombie ne
crois pas noté qui circulait dans sa
balle fois l'exemple il a déjà sonné
victorieusement toutes les classes le
dégel religieuse brageot t'excuser d'or
tu arrives le voit ridiculous en
convient chercheurs il appelait aussi à
vous d'apprendre que le terrain est
épouvantable aucune importance de la
scène quand on fait dans le gras on peut
faire dans le lourd mes chevaux sont
assez salée pour les couleurs sont
propres et je me suis laissé dire que
mademoiselle et brûlées gardent à la
fille du président de la rafale ne
laissez pas votre cas est différent
alors là ces conditions comme j'ai un
coeur moi aussi je comprends facilement
enfin si vous me comprenez quoi c'est
qu'un président c'est moi qui
comprendraient plus rien au rugby
malgré ce fait j'ai oublié mais sur sa
tour allait me kattié suivez le château
on verra
c'est mignon
couleurs et tout dans mon bulletin
paroissial
toi au moins tu les bronches par rick
grand tort que tu es mort pour la france
c'est le rugby et mais qui nous fait
gagner le ciel crient tous les matins je
prie le bon dieu pour qu'il nous donne
une méritoire ensemble de modèles
taillés dans le bronze coups et de le
faire enlever les bâtis sur pierre le
mérite quand même monument eu une mais
elle se mettra le loup de morieux lemay
l'air du temps ce n'était pas tu n'étais
pas un peu de sel et de temps en temps
comme ça histoire que tu aimes président
tu veux l'airé qui donnait bien le
revermont des aînés c'est le bon dieu
lui même qui l'a dit il vaut mieux
donner que recevoir et qui c'est qui qui
faisait le visu pour le coup et hier au
caire
qu'est-ce qui m'a fichu cette sonnerie
le clan je vais vous expliquer mon cher
président c'est une idée qui m'est venue
comme ça d'une sorte de téléphone
paroissiens 62 coups pour la rafale
depuis trois petits coups comme ça pour
la fierté histoire histoire de leur
flanquer le bourdon 63 mais quand vous y
aller mais vous nous et elle fait plein
de choses à nous mais avait laissé à
quatre points c'est la vie marine qui
n'entend qu'une cloche n'entend qu'un
son pourvu que le bon dieu la gonorrhée
annonça le bon dieu je m'en occupe c'est
mon affaire je lui demande toujours le
double pour qu'il me donne la moitié
estime simon la ferme on écoute dit on
avait volé au siège
allez-y devant et je vous rejoins dans
une petite minute hué le partant de nos
garçons
et là
élever les autres forts il jette un peu
loin le bouchon l'avait 63 oui je sois
pas le contraire l'établissement qui
déborde
vous allez bientôt achever la mission
d'aboutir et sancho pas tout comme
d'habitude les causes relatives aux mecs
trop 10 et elle a fait le droit que
l'eau mais pas les jeunes olivier mutter
trappe et bâtiments dans le bouillant
d'entraîneur de matériel
il a plutôt mon défunt notre époque où
j'aurai décidé et les hommes et de
claude laval
je n'aime pas cela paraît plus au buzzer
de la rappelle c'est le siège de 60 des
traditions les parisiens série bd vous
dans votre aveu un par les avis de décès
il ya pas de quoi trembler
et clients de la classe barrés fric et
moi je parie 40 dollar pour la fierté de
la bassée fait de ne chercher pas plus
longtemps
le gagnant de la bourriche se sont
engagés en terrorisme on revient de la
recherche et la bourriche et il faudra
nous permettre avec les gants blancs
rien dû à tous affectés ou pas il faut
se faire le grand père ratisseur parole
aux ballons pointu patrice couronne
chaubard faudra que je vous assure c'est
contre ce genre d'actes ou une assurance
vous pour venir un pack d'abord monsieur
c'est comme une chappe ça s'accroche à
une étoile aussi c'est l'espérance c'est
la fois avec mais pour la charité excusé
il avait excusé pour les pros ou avec ma
bécane tu fais de mal à personne
tandis que dans votre mail en effet
jésus pour le coach c'est vous-même qui
l'état est ce à dire monsieur réunion
que vous n'assisterez même pas notre
derby j'ai un vélo tout neuf pour une
gentille je vais pas laisser passer un
dimanche comme ça sans rouler et puis
saurez tout en lisant l'article de
monsieur lacrampe la lumière du rébel la
gazette de l'est saurez tout sur les
exploits de boîtes qaïda ya pas de doute
il défend bien en toutes circonstances
d'ailleurs le passé à leurs enfants
si seulement lui le me donne un ballon
je vous promets je fais un malheur
m
il
jamais les petits orange et aujourd'hui
ils sont à votre portée les trois rivaux
malheureux que le meilleur gagne et un
seul vainqueur
l affaire
et
oh
non
m
mais si présidence il n'y avait rien
oui
m
avant même touche
allez
il a joué
la lumière entre sa promesse apprend
mais président bravo
ok
vous allez au loup
et
ouais
à
oh
elle s'inquiète tout seul que la semaine
est camille qui a vu un tiers
si vous lui accrocher le fast food aux
fesses on n'est pas picorer faire
démasquer 6 président
et
oh
mais non
m
une explication prudent
visant les souliers charger vos plantes
ils n'ont pas mis naissante dallas
revient tous les ballons
kalou mieux
honteux
m
grâce à lui nous sommes allés la rafale
la côte est
alors que
le voir ouais ouais voilà encore deux de
plus
le palais à paris
j'imagine
t
la jeune couple a eu
alors aux armes se dire au charme c'est
mon seul un tel désastre que vous avez
ici dans le désert
ça promet
ils sont coincés entre le terril hamel
pouvez aussi opter par terre c'est pas
des joueurs assez les paroles
ely et lila masse à petit c'est comme ça
que tu vas les entraîne camille au
brésil à jean voyageur classe et vol là
c'est qu'ils veulent avoir des amis
pareils vous pouvez toujours les
paiements d'intérêts ou la ferai pas des
zèbres
c'est comme se furent et nous parler de
capitaine
le vrai passoire des farces à ça qu'il
n'arrêterait pas le monde en aucun temps
c'est pas trop grave mais il faudra
qu'il se repose un certain et je trouve
ces adultes est en très mauvais état a
les adducteurs et encore ces cas malik
d'adducteurs c'est la maladie du siècle
les adducteurs dit le docteur j'ai joué
quinze ans sans toi est ce que j'avais
mal aux adducteurs première nouvelle
alors voilà bonjour je suis navré pour
monsieur le garde
je suis navré pour toi c'est grave
maintenant on va encore et pour l'heure
apple c'est une grosse blessure c'est ça
embrassez vous pendant que vous y êtes
déjà loué ce que j'ai rêvé ou bien les
assassins de monsieur ton pris pour un
paillasson
comme ton père était président de la
fierté on se fichait peut-être de beni
mais il y avait la manière on ne
s'habille mais pas les amis pierre je me
demande ce que ma fille on peut trouver
le cadre
je me garderai bien que j'ai tout fait
pour calmer les esprits allez allez tous
au diable j'ai besoin d'être un seul ça
ne me suffit pas d'avoir une équipe de
canard boiteux il faut encore une fille
qui s'amourache de la nuit oui mais vous
me taper sur les adducteurs
ces contrats allez tu veux combien
d'avoir sciemment allait rentrer chez
toi il repose toi hein
thébaux
tél
maladivement
l'élite de la dsfm ne faut pas d'arrêt
jamais draft
du
ce n'est tout de même pas sorcier
lors de l'es7 el melh après la victoire
et c'est toi le débit direct et
naturellement pas le pour te faire la
protection mais regardez-moi ça quand
les joies se mettent à faire de l'esprit
ou mécanique
nous voyons la coupe jusqu'à la lie ils
t'ont fait sa une à l'homme pardon bamba
dit il faut lui faire sa toilette
ces témoins de la douceur le pitre denis
ravisseurs la troisième ligne les
martyrs mois les 40 poids et les gifles
je pardonne mais pas ça il va même
tendance le p-dg de la mode
il va s'en souvenir de notre vin
d'honneur président de la rafale je suis
maire de sainte-colombe je vais te lui
coller un de ces trous de règle sur les
doigts j'espère bien monsieur
mais on peut faire ça mais c'est pas
possible
passe encore qu'ils nous humilient sur
le prêt qu'ils nous humilient sur la
place mais ne pas venir aux vins
d'honneur c'est un crime contre le répit
ce puits de la mort mon port il n'a de
respect pour rien la semil yade ses
usines ses avions c'est partout à
travers le monde la saq a remonté
n'entend parler que de ça il demandait
pas encore d'être la can n'est pas
évident alors mon coin c'est à dire et
qu'il a un homme dépossédé l'univers
venait d'atteindre son arme un manquait
plus que ça peut bien faire c'est la
prise ou encore ce vieux de résister
parfaitement qu'ici à pallier talantais
de la table pour arrêter par la pie ix
enfin si la police monsieur lacombe
monsieur jules l'accord j'espère que
nous irons ça aussi demain dans le
réveil comme un postier on vous respecte
mais comme journaliste dame depuis que
monsieur pic dans la mode achète tout
dans ce département les châteaux le
rugby tout la volaille et même votre
canard mais je ne suis pas savoir
monsieur le maire et surtout la crempse
ne vous découvrez pas comme dans vos
articles
la compagnie c'est dans la veille et
libérale qui tout au val
mais on est là c'est quoi que vous avez
la vallée des fois l'ont vu le masque
monsieur prix de la mode est passée par
là je voyais bien tard et que lui n'en
est pas bon ça va j'ai compris
maintenant ils viendront plus
prédisposés mes amis mais je veux tout
le monde à l'entraînement de mardi c'est
compris le challenge taillefer continue
rappelez-vous ceci aujourd'hui la fierté
de la bastide nous a humiliés
mais elle a perdu la troisième mi temps
c'est plus important et j ai tenu ce
soir à vous faire les honneurs n'en
connaissent ne meurt c'est parce que je
voulais que ce que vous appelez la
troisième mi temps soit à la mesure du
teilleul secours devaient l'emporter aux
dépens d'un rival séculaire
quand je salue ici le boulard le et le
sympathique président à la personne de
mademoiselle voilà
vous me connaissez assez mieux
maintenant la plupart d'entre vous que
j'ai le plaisir d'employés dans les
entreprises savent que j'aime les sommes
qui gâte
vous avez gagné que je ne serai pas nés
quand monsieur j'ai placé mon
collaborateur
il est chargé de donner une impulsion
nouvelle à la fierté de la bastide
grâce à des méthodes plus modernes a
reçu mes instructions
à ce sujet vous avez fait le plus
difficile pour la conquête du seul enjeu
taillefer
mais le plat ici solennellement
l'engagement que si vous ramener ce
trophée à la bastide
je ferai pour l'équipe la plus enviée et
la plus heureuse de toute leur vie à
celle ci
kiev la scène mondiale l'homme qui
faisait commission et qui n'oublie
jamais de prendre la sienne il peut la
garder son angle mort et puis je suis
dans mes persos
présidant la chaîne ce numéro 10 là la
face aux jets l'extrême sentiment qui ne
servira plus longtemps il me le faut la
scène ils veulent fois la fierté à
n'importe quel pirate school à
l'investir président qu'il arrête les
régler mon chien djilani gnagnagna la
formule habituelle mais alors me taper
red bulls qu un joli nom bien volleyé
pourquoi je montrais matelas pour le
transit mais rien compris alors
impossible à paris ok
comme il n'est pas à l'être pour
l'attacher à l'ambassade de france à
washington et 90 au réveil ce n'est
vraiment pas raisonnable cher monsieur
regardez-moi ça c'est aux acteurs que
j'ai commencé je sais qu'à trouver du
pétrole faisant des patterns le sable et
à quel âge et un batave au poker la
baraka de choses le président est seul
face à mon talent à l'epa voulez vous
que je mange quand le fait les choses ce
sont les seuls qui neutralisent
c'est ce que vous appelez à les planter
vos choux l'attachant je le connais pas
docteur le connais que trop lui serait
18 14
c'est peut-être un très joli score de
rugby mais je ne saurait garantir à mes
confrères de la capitale que vous suivez
votre cure de repos suivant leurs
prescriptions bien là qu'est ce qu'on
dit cette de colombes dans la victoire
et ma fierté c'est bien simple vous êtes
tous atteints du même virus la challenge
it
voilà comment je m'appelle la challenge
it et si je puis me permettre ce simple
jeu de mots et qu'alexandre dumas malbar
d'hommes vous lisez trop de romans de
pâques et d'épée la scène
alors en vous il m'est vraiment
désagréable je vous prie de vous
déranger je confierai j'appelle mon
colis et de télé la scène alors que bâle
où il est ses chèvres liste vous
apprendre ne peut pas tout de suite
bon comme n'est pas ce que l'on dit hier
soir la nouvelle ce numéro 10
aujourd'hui bordeaux entre en contact
avec ma maman c'est le fromage un très
fort match elle même était vraiment le
petit à souper et non mais c'est un
président et non vers les aguerris des
nouvelles de jean louis secours je suis
en mesure de vous en donner
vous l'avez mis dans un bel état qu'est
ce qu'il fait là bas il fait ses études
de pharmacie à bordeaux doit communiquer
avec la sécurité sociale c'est un peu le
cas des pharmaciens alors on attend le
corps médical
si vous voulez aux gémonies la trempe là
g de lait caillé
je me demande comment on peut écrire
dans le réveil avec l'air aussi endormie
n'est point est il exact que vous ayez
racheter les parts de seconde un
exaoctet l'exo michou
mais là y'a la chaîne ce colombien est
laissé pour qu'il me rejoigne d'escrocs
alors beaucoup de vidéos sur la rafale
aura simplement jeter la poudre aux yeux
des supporteurs particulièrement logo
car sitôt que la raf en ce compris
zhang est clos par un coup du sort la
personne coup du sort mais moi je
pressens que favori le derby tant
attendu de l'inde un prion en face à
sens unique
aulas moderne formation de la fierté de
la bastille encore un grand succès à
verser à l'acte i de monsieur oscar pill
de la mode
l'industriel mondialement connue
bienfaiteur alternateur cochon de la
cambre les larbins
oui ma petite wii une photo coucher des
fois je te coucher que tu préfères tu
t'habilles et je t'en prie ça va être
quoi
si on ne fait rien maintenant papa c'est
quoi il faut bien que le devis se trouve
sa moitié
encore un grand succès à verser à
l'actif de monsieur oscar pill de la
motte l'industriel mondialement connue
bienfaiteur de sa terre natale surpris
hier pour notre dame de l'ovale imprimer
les horreurs pareilles je me consacre
que je fasse de grévaux testemale exiger
un démenti non là mais non il faut
parler aux grands patrons il faut parler
à piles de la moitié cette semaine vous
avez raison de ses seins contre un
bélier bille en tête tout enfant je veux
groupe et cela va vous mettre dans des
états pareils pour vos histoires de mes
large qu'elle mélange une bonne fois
pour toute et antoine on ne dit pas
mélange on dit mary simple calcul mental
mes enfants la rafale a perdu par 40 2 à
4 mais si dimanche prochain et le baléti
news de la bidassoa par 18 à 3 voici les
maintient en tenue mercredi tous les
deux pour vous apprendre je poursuis et
si comme en ces temps là la fierté de la
bastide se fait battre par la furia
roussillonnaise mettons par 12
à s'excuser
est-ce que c'est là qu'on s'est permis
de vous déranger pendant votre premier
disque l affaire hier à sainte colome
par une température particulièrement
bien tenez c'est particulièrement
heureux de jaloux car sitôt que la
rafale se trouvent privés de jaloux
desclaud par un coup du sort
le derby tant attendu devait un triomphe
à sens unique pour la moderne formation
de la fierté d'un mastic n'est pas
encore un grand succès à bercy à l'actif
de monsieur oscar tweet de lamotte
l'industriel mondialement connue
bienfaiteur de sa terre natale
bienfaiteur de sa terne
vous allez bien fait la bêtise exagère
c'est pour les enfants
il se produit en cas de force majeure
vous savez que si le challenge taillefer
devait partir pour la bastide si ce
grand malheur devait se produire un jour
ce qu'à dieu ne plaise au mieux la
commune il vous appartiendrais mes
petits de nous le ramener à sainte
colombe
c'est dans cette perspective douloureuse
mais glorieuse
c'est dans cette perspective que je vais
vous dans les récréations jusqu'à mairie
attention pas de dissipation pendant mon
absence je vous convie à monsieur
testemale à qui vous devez obéir
cleantech et je groupe et de ses
merveilles abada merveilleux vous êtes
également d'accord pour qu'on puisse
venir de venir ici très bien monsieur
quitté la route sur l'a13 et je sais
c'est bon les gars de la weser savane
bonjour messieurs lise chacun pélissier
attaché de presse ma très chère attaché
de presse et les mesures à l'honneur de
ses prises
photo ila si vous le permettez monsieur
nous resterons debout pour vous rappeler
que le challenge taillefer est une
épreuve par invitation que la manière y
apporte plus que le résultat la
tradition plus que la méthode la
tradition de ce qui du vivant du grand
clovis taillefer fiancée plus valeureux
adversaires ses compagnons de combat de
ceux qui ont fait du rugby la plus jolie
guerre du temps de paix une chose
monsieur qui ne se marchande pas qui ne
s'achètent pas comme le reste 10 falla
servait de l'investissement nos aimables
visiteurs mais avec plaisir oui ce
qu'ils portent en rien du tout n'a rien
du tout rien du tout les sens mais les
rafraîchissements lara fans les avaient
préparés pour vous alors sacrée du vin
d'honneur car je vous répète que ce
challenge fait de vous nos invités
écoutez montbarbon semaine dans leur
cinéma la rue ainsi que les personnes
informées rosa de votre fille
non je vous le passez pour le vin
d'honneur
mais vous avez odieusement agressé notre
meilleur joueur
profaner la statue ridiculiser les
rafales dans votre journal vous avez
sorti les gros bâton évoluera nous
sommes fiers que j'aime les hommes à qui
gagne mais je finis repas-concert pas
perdre dans les affaires monsieur vous
êtes un monument mais dans le rugby vous
est encore un peu jeune
or la mtc vous du rugby non et puis
piquent de la montre c'est pas une
langue qui fait la beauté noire est ce
que me gêne c'est trump a fait la bière
allaitantes hausse à la ronde et vote
ostrogoths là il est rugby comme moi je
suis évêque par pitié oscar cette
représentation et d'un grotesque et d'un
pénible
nous sommes pauvres mademoiselle la
rafale et pauvres moi aussi j'étais
pauvre et je maman tu te mon empire les
gagner on attendait gagner il n'y a pas
d' enveloppe chez nous monsieur puig de
la motte
tout ce qu'on y gagne au rugby c'est 55
50 sacs de patates ou de ciment à
décharger le lundi matin
tout ce qu on y attrape c'est une bonne
soif une oreilles en chou-fleur et un
maillot bien trempé histoire de bien
transpiré ses péchés et le rugby
monsieur vous n'allez pas nous l'abîmé
avec vos millions et te l'avait allaité
votre serment
l'histoire du pot de terre la presse à
l'école enfantine
moi je voulais tendre la main à tous les
gens cette région mais puisque metz
comme ayant la chance je vous apprendrai
pas encore mis d'accord ce avantageuse à
monsieur au besoin je les fabrique
les miracles monsieur vous avez dit les
miracles et bien les miracles c'est chez
moi qu on les fabrique monsieur mon dieu
et tout mais pouvant y passer monsieur
l'abbé est avec moi tous finiront avec
le bon dieu fera un miracle dans le
droit ni le furane ira au notre-dame de
leval fait que la rafale notre dame de
la milice fait que la fierté ce monsieur
l'abbé croates emmené vous comme ça
et dans chaque fois l'otan derrida temps
vous verrez ouvert et antoine nous
allons faire un beau voyage même qu'on
voyage avec miracles au fort heureux
miracle
voyez-vous quand il se pèsent tous en
simples mots à part j'ai toujours
l'impression que c'est pour dire du mal
des autres à la télévision c'est quand
même ce que je préfère moi lemay large
palmer lawes d'antoine par le mélange la
mêlée la mêlée d'amélie et la belgique
s'est fixé d'une communion et d'une
réduction et la fête de passe en juste
qu'est ce que vous appelez une feinte de
passe et de feintes de passe passe pas
je vous entends départ également de
rentrer de rentrer à embellir leur
apprends béni je vais vous dire c'est
qu'on les grands esprits soient d'accord
les grades souvent comme un dictionnaire
dites moi dit le fragment d'os qui t'as
qu'à rome j'en tirais tout autant de
votre petit vin blanc monsieur testemale
on devient cavani
rien ne va c'est le manque 15 jours ou
trois semaines de retour ce qui pouvait
m'arriver de mieux jouer les autres tu
sais pas tout ne va pas se sèche avec un
bal en juillet c'est bien joli mais y'a
pas que la voir talent et dis-moi
comment tu trouves que papa n'est pas un
bon entraîneur de la rafale de vienne 38
pour toi qu'est-ce que tu vas chercher
tu me demandez pas pourquoi je suis pas
la claque aujourd'hui pourquoi je suis
revenu au bercail
enfin encore du 152 moyenne depuis
bordeaux écoute potes c'est un secret
demain avec ma mère je vais dîner chez
pic de la motte pour moi pour nous c'est
peut-être le grand virage à 200 à
l'heure et dans une auto tout neuf qui
ne te coûtera pas cher ne fait pas si
tout est ok rien de fait mais t'aimerais
pas je sais pas moins voyager rêver
partir un peu loin enfin vivre rêvait
j'en où je ne fais que ça suffirait de
limonadiers et wav fils de pharmacien
antisioniste il est beau comme on dit si
les verts tiens tu sais ce qu'on va
faire on va les voir les copains à
l'entraînement mais c'est gentil de ta
part mais il n'y a pas d'eau
il a bien joué à panneaux pleins la
bastide
histoire de leur donner d'autres misères
spectacle non ça va s'arranger ça à
faire écho miracle peut-être les beaux
mister avocats malik on perd
d'internement pour aller on pourrait pas
savoir où la fin non mais nous sommes
sur la bonne route
nous suivons les voies du seigneur
pendant sept mois confiance aujourd'hui
on en train de l'isard on va retrouver
la foi de les regarder se veut au
verdict
regardez à vous autres regardez regardez
c'est ce qu'on appelle un chef-d'oeuvre
aux religieux des hommes sont sous le
régime féodal cette imposante église
exerçait sa toute puissance temporelle
et employés et spirituelle sur le petit
castrum de sainte colombe
car il faut vous bien que sainte colombe
et la basse tiré de son temps séparés
seulement par 6 10 6 km de routes
nationales non non mes enfants ne sont
séparés par par les siècles des siècles
et les siècles au moyen de ce monument
que la bastide nous écraser les plus
regardées regarder encore et c'est ma
maison
asus et demeure bourgeoise aux murs
épais ce sont ces pâles comment cette
série c'est regarder on verrait ses
vieux souvenirs
dites vous bien mes amis
ici nous sommes à la bastille la
bastille la bastille sa sous préfecture
sur l'iss et l'acception ses joies la
bastide et sa fierté
nous sommes faits puig de la mort de
huit de lamotte lampe d'horreur comme se
renouvelle encore de la plume longue
période
l'onmt horreur de tout ouais c'est beau
non
non mais j'ai pu de la mode n'a pas
encore tout volé j'ai l'impression que
ça y est il est plus une étrangère à la
bastide encore une chance et du maire de
sainte-colombe président de la rafale
qui avait tout pour plaire la bastide
public on me voit qu'avec le meilleur
joueur de la fierté meilleur dépêche toi
de le dire sinon comme il ya quatre ans
on est déjà doute côté de la colline
contraire je me sens tout neuf mais tout
neuf pour autre chose quoi tu comprends
ingénieur chez pic de la mode qu'est ce
que tu veux du milieu que je deviens tu
viens de le dire franchement profiter de
ce pays regarde regarde tout ce qu'il ya
à faire
regarde pas se taire bien sûr si papa ne
l'avait pas vendu une usine peut-être
que j'y serais resté tantôt réduit pour
ce qu'ils sont en train d'enfer puis de
lamotte et larsen
alors ce que je voudrais c'est la
travailler tu comprends mais cette année
avec toi à prendre une ferme quitter
tout quoi carrément quitté toute équité
tout entendu michel becker ce qui va
dire peuvent pas je t'aurais bien le
convaincre
romain lui et son équipe sa mairie sa
rafale mais tu te rends pas compte mon
enfance à la maison j'ai entendu parler
que de la afa et encore de la alors
c'était pas ma fille
y a pas classe aujourd'hui on fait quand
même plus toi papa
bonjour je regarde et là alors on ce
problème puisque les oies ne viennent
pas photo les élus vite faut bien que ce
soit les canards qui se dérangent on
peut pas pas justement pour ce vin
d'honneur salle et moi ne te fatigue pas
je vois que la vie est douce et la
bastide losc avait dit papa tu vas pas
mon nom je voudrais seulement remonter
dans cet autobus alors là
non mais on y va tenez regardez je vous
le disais le mia allez vous devez
l'écouter
mais monsieur l'abbé mais nous sommes
sur la route 2 c'est le pélerinage en
terre promenade me la copierez l'abbé
tout aussi qu à malibu pour accrocher
lobé clients l'avant et c'est bien à
lourdes que nous allons retrouver la foi
d' nous allons tous revenir meilleur que
nous ne sommes partis oui oui bien sûr
la drogue et bien sûr ma chère macerata
thuan vpn nous y passeront peut-être au
retour si nous avons de cinq minutes
parce que au nombre des monuments qui se
visite à lourdes il ya aussi le jeu
c'est pas moi le le château fort et est
encore et surtout il ya le grand
monument du rugby français celui qui
nous intéresse celui que nous allons
rencontrer celui que les britanniques
ont surnommé monsieur rugby
seul celui qui dit qui a fait se lever
les foules qui est qui qui a fait courir
les paralytiques eu ce grand capitaine
de l'équipe de france qui a fait des
miracles hattrick nam et à et à colombes
il y a jean prat ça y est j'ai compris
on va voir le pape le pape par le pape
du rugby d'attaqué
il va là il va nous faire des miracles
vous verrez des niayes
c'était une belle comme l'âge et jean
cointe a été bien accueillant il faut
pas rêver voyance comme il est bien
gentil monsieur rugby il a fait semblant
de nous prendre au sérieux pour plus
important qu'aux tue pas non je vais
mais il faut garder les pieds sur terre
jambe droite
c'est le rugby au sommet et la rafale
c'est le 36e dessous comme toi mon ami
je te prépare une de ces caps ont tu as
déjà un pied dans le précipice et
l'autre sur une peau de banane une mêlée
qui recule et une défense qui prend
l'eau de partout dizaines sous dans la
caisse demi de mêlée qui s'appelle furet
qui ne voient jamais le trou alors quand
jean prat nous dit le rugby
mes amis c'est un jeu anglais si vous
voulez bien joué lui écouter les anglais
regardez les anglais trouvez-vous en
anglais bien joli mais où vous dites
qu'on le trouve je leur parle de tomber
du ciel
où veux tu que je trouve un anglais
office
que de conserver longtemps ont reculé
alors j'ai bien joué j'ai encore le goût
un soutien est grande plus tiennent
beaucoup en soutane lever la main sur
l'a46 à l'as far away conserver l'appui
elle aurait conservé le challenge de
taille aux fringues et jolie vient bien
joli grand père mais qui vous dit que la
rafale va perdre le challenge et à evry
si nous gagnons dimanche contre les
puces tous les espaces de côté au plus
tard oui vous pouvez ou millions de
tests mal qui veut se les mettre à
l'anglais ses piliers parce que vous les
connaissez voulait il nous faut de
l'envié en saura un peu plus pour
mémoire articulé par moment avant que
c'est pas certain qu'ils vont peiner en
1931 justement votre vertèbres combat
seul avant lui les piliers on ne va pas
les mettre à l'engrais on va en changer
germinal et benjamin la pie ix
nous prenons la paire voix mais ne
semble pas toujours tendre à l'arrière
des objets le côté droit
pour mes deux dans la pierre c'est
d'accord mais attention je pose les
conditions quelles conditions ventées
vous dirai aux clients de tests mal que
c'est moi qui ai gagné la bourriche et
que j'ai dit je dis me la remettre avec
les gants blancs c'est bien je veux qu
peu partout dans cette équipe de la
technique de la tactique de
l'entraînement et même du recrutement
l'a longuement parce que vous avez aussi
recruté par l'opération du saint-esprit
le saint-esprit monsieur gain de vous
pouvez le remercier pour les deux pays
que je vous amène téplier d'épuiser pour
dix marches j'ai bien réfléchi mes amis
pour dimanche
il faut mettre les as droit devant il
faut reprendre les la pierre les la
ville mais ne sont pas sortable pas
sortable j'ai fait et c'est dire s'ils
sont pas sages ont les groupes de rap il
va bien rigoler le ballon mais la pigne
vu des gens capables d'attraper c'est
possible mais pour ce qui est de pousser
une louve rumba honte et vit d'ailleurs
et 9 ans anna doit se relever que pour
adopter çà comme les députés de la
majorité
vous savez que c'est du propre la bce
vous manigancé vous allez faire vos
émotions chez jean pattes est en fait de
bonnes résolutions qu'est ce que vous
nous ramenez les deux monstres lesieu
vieux père et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
daomé gay comme ça les enfants de la
commune un site c'est le rôle d'un
entraîneur ça c'est le rôle de mère y
avait un coup de téléphone pour vous que
de la part de qui ma bonne dame
je n'ai pas demandé vous l'avez pas
demandé
mais alors cité six est important mais
si c'était important
mais c'était sûrement pas le pape non
justement macamic et si cet exemple tu
rates jean prat
et pourquoi faire graver droite sauf si
vous avez oublié votre parapluie chez
nous pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils vous
appelle vous ne croyez pas tout de même
tu vas nous avons accepté d'animer nos
lacs b pour la rafale reste mal vous me
décevez beaucoup je vous emmène à
lourdes et vous me perdais la foi a dit
chen lei qui vous plaît et qui sait que
je ne plaisantais paraît que c'est chose
est sûre avec la semaine est ce que mon
ami jean prat cousin téléphonie je subis
tu fortune a plus de match enchantée je
suis acheté de foie gras et m'ennuie
jean pattes m'a dit que vous connaissez
toutes les adresses de levage dans nos
régions gens parce que c'est nous
megan jean prat bien sûr je tenais à
vous et venez je vais m'occuper l'a
voulu le suivre alors c'est ces gens
pratiquer vous rajoutez un coupé